vie c est rapé chuté pour la plus grande
joie des petits mais aussi des grands
une patinoire en plein air a pris place
devant l'hôtel de ville de versailles
pour la quatrième année consécutive une
patinoire particulière elle est
écologique
elle sanctionne sans eau sans
électricité et les plaques de
polyoléfines peuvent être réutilisés
plusieurs fois ces autos lubrifié donc
on n'a quand même pas encore tout à fait
à qualité la vraie glace mais ça
commence à rapprocher
et comme on nous avons nous à feu deux
sur place qui nous permet d'affûter les
patins relativement tout temps à la
quand même glisse qui reste très correct
par rapport à la vraie glace quand même
un petit temps d'adaptation parce que
j'ai vraiment pas l'habitude de faire de
la patinoire synthétique moins dur que
la glace véritable en cas de chute mais
aussi son humidité où ils risquent pas
d'être mouillés et d'attraper froid
c'est excellent c'est un peu différent
du parthe pata ordinaire c'est un peu
faut un petit temps d'adaptation mais
c'est marrant
et pour reprendre des forces gaufres
crêpes et boissons chaudes régale les
visiteurs c'est génial c'est super les
enfants s'amusent bien et on passe un
très bon moment on a l'impression d'être
en vacances avant l'heure chaque année
entre 5000 et 6000 patineurs viennent
s'exercer sur la patinoire éphémère qui
restera ouverte jusqu'au 6 janvier